- Good morning, I think I'm audible properly.
Good morning everyone.
So today I welcome you in the hands-on session
on clustering techniques where we are going to discuss
about the next phase after the supervised learning.
Like if we don't have a labeled data,
how we can work with that kind of data.
So this is a very important aspect of machine learning
which we are using in our day-to-day life
as well as with bigger models
that we are going to discuss in some time.
So the general idea I think you have all gone through
this supervised machine learning algorithm
along with that you have gone through different techniques
and basically the coding of the practical implementation
of these techniques.
So it will be quite similar to what you have already done.
The only difference will be that previously
we were dealing with data which had level.
So what is level is basically you have the features
of the data points along with that you have some information
about the data that is basically which class
that particular data belongs to.
But right now we are dealing with clustering techniques
that means we are going to deal with data
which does not have a label associated with it.
Why doesn't we have a label is another question
because the issue with label is that you have to label
the data by yourself, right?
So all the label data that we have till now
most of them are being generated by human beings
and those are being called as the ground truth
or the star data.
And if you don't have that kind of data
there are other techniques by you can label the data.
There are synthetic methods where you can create the data
and you can label the data
but those are not that much reliable.
So most of the data that is generated
for supervised training is being labeled by human beings.
And as you can understand that if human beings
are labeling the data that will be costly
and that will be difficult to like have a data
of sufficient size in most of the aspects.
So there comes this technique
where we don't have a label data
but yet we want to have some group of information.
So as you can see in my screen
that I have shown you a basic technique
or basic idea about what is clustering.
So in clustering you can see in the left hand side
we have different shape.
So what does these shapes represent?
These shapes represent different features
that these particular items contain.
Now there will be a machine learning model.
There will be some kind of training or something like that.
And then there will be some predictions.
So basically output from the model.
And when we get an output from the model
the output will be that this belongs to a group of circle
or this belongs to a group of squares.
Now how do we get that, right?
So as you can understand if you just see this picture
that there are different shapes
and if we consider the different vertices and edges, right?
So for each of the shapes
we can have two different parameters
or two different attributes that represent the shapes.
One of them is let's say vertices.
So for triangle there will be three vertices and three edges.
So like this you have different shapes
you will have different kind of activity associated with it.
Now this machine learning model
which is right now a clustering model
or an unsupervised model
because you are not supervising it.
You are not giving any kind of labeled information beforehand.
Here you have to recognize the pattern
between these two features.
Basically the vertices and edges.
Maybe color is also one of the aspect
that you can consider but not here.
So once you have that information
and your model is able to capture that information
that with different vertices the shapes will be different.
With different edges the shapes will be different.
Then you can have groups
where for example you will have a group
where all the three vertices objects are placed
and there are baskets where like for example
some more than three or four vertices
are there that will be placed, something like that.
So once you have these kind of groups available to you
you can put any new object that comes.
You can just check that what is the attribute values
or the values present in that particular object.
For example the age is let's say seven
and the vertices is eight.
Then in that case you can just pick that
and put it in a separate group that it represents.
Now in this picture you can see that there is
the term circle written, the star written, the rectangle.
So every object has been identified by its level.
But in reality when we are doing clustering algorithm
we don't know what the level will be.
We just know that they will fall in different groups
and if they are in different groups
that means they are different
but we cannot name them properly.
So this naming convention will differ.
Probably you will name those after you have clustered
and then maybe some human will come
and see that what this dataset contains
or this group contains and then they will name
that particular group.
But naming of each of the object is not possible here.
So let's just start by getting the idea
of rapid machine learning application development.
So this you will see in most of the ML classes.
So here the first thing that comes
is the understanding of the dataset.
So once you have this dataset you have to go
through the dataset you have to understand
what the dataset means and what the dataset requires.
So if you have been given a problem statement
for example you have been given a dataset
and a problem together then it's quite easy
to just grab the problem and know the solution
and if you know the solution you can just apply
the formulation that needed.
But if you have a dataset and you don't have the problem
with you which is a real case
with any of the real life problems.
So when we are dealing with real life problems
we might not have the problems that we are going to solve.
We might not have the questions that has been asked.
So here we have to understand the dataset
and you have to curate the problems by yourself.
So once you have this dataset
and understanding of the dataset
and you can identify the problem
that you are going to solve with this dataset
then you can select the suitable models.
So if you have the problem statement with you beforehand
you can just skip this step
and you can go to the selection of suitable models.
To understand the suitable models
you have to go through some of the theory aspect
that you are being taught in this sessions.
So once you get the idea about how a particular model works
on which particular dataset a model will perform better
and what are the different aspects of a particular model
then you'll be able to pick at least some aspects
of those models.
So you can pick some models that might work properly.
But of course if you are not experimenting
then you don't have the idea
about what particular model will be performing best
because there may be like a selection of five or 10 algorithms
that you can pick for a particular job.
So once you have this model selected
basically you have a subset of model selected
then you can perform the experiments.
So performing experiments means for a clustering algorithm
we'll have this dataset where the problem
we have the different algorithms
we will perform the experiments
we will run the clustering algorithms on this data
and we'll have some results with us.
Once we have this result you will see
that there is a selection of best model kind of thing.
So what this does is you will select the best model
based on different evaluation criteria
that has been provided.
So different machine learning models
will have different criteria that can be used
for evaluating a particular model on a particular dataset.
So if you have a dataset
if you have a model run experiment
and you get an evaluation score
now from there you can get a good outcome
or good model that you can select from.
Here in the select based model
there is also another aspect which is cross validation
where you can tune the hyper parameters
that are present in a model.
I think that will be out of scope of this particular lecture
but eventually or even before this class
probably you have heard of it.
So where we tune the parameters of a particular model
to get the best model out of it.
So this is the general idea
I think this is quite simple to understand.
Now let's understand the first algorithm
that we are going to deal with.
It is known as the K-Means clustering algorithm.
It is a very, very famous algorithm.
Previously when it was the era of only machine learning
we were used to this machine learning algorithms
to solve many different aspects of problems in real life.
In industries they use this kind of algorithms a lot
for their purposes.
But the main thing that is important at this current stage
where we have transformers, deep learning methods
and bigger large language models
you can understand that this particular algorithms
are still useful in those aspects
to train those models and to see how those model works.
So we will see some aspect of that in today's hands on
but let's get started with today's hands on.
So we have this data set here.
And before starting like I'm just going to show you
some information that this is a GitHub page.
The link has been provided to you.
So if you go to this link we'll have all the lectures,
today's lectures material that is present here.
I think if you can just open this lecture material today
and then you can just write and the code
alongside what I'm doing then it will be very helpful
for you to get through this particular hands on.
So go to this like repository
where we have this notebooks, different notebooks
and we have two different sets of data set.
One is housing.csv, another is wine.csv
and we'll be working on these data sets.
So let's start with this.
So now I am just going to show you this data set.
Just let's see some of the data points that are present here.
So even if the font size for this one is lower
I think you can just grab the notebook
that has been provided to you.
This information you'll get there also
and eventually you have to copy this data
from that notebook to get the hands on started.
So you see that we have this very simple data set
that I've created for this class
for you to understand the basics of clustering algorithm.
So here we have two subjects
and there are multiple students.
For example, there are 20 students here
and there are two subjects
and there are some numerical values assigned to each of
the student and subject attributes.
So if we have this kind of data set
the first problem that comes to our mind
is that we don't have any problem statement given to us
that we were discussing.
And if we don't have any problem statement given to us
with this data set, what can I do?
So if I have this data set
and the very basic thing that I can do
is I can plot this data set.
This will be a two dimensional data set
and each of the student in that particular data set
in this particular data set
will represent a particular data point.
So each student represents a data point
and each subject represents the attribute.
Don't go through the fact that there are multiple columns
and the rows that can be interchanged, right?
So for this particular aspect from my understanding
I have decided that the students will be the data points
and subjects will be the attributes
that represent the student, right?
So let's just first see that if we plot this data
what we get, right?
So let's run the code first.
So here you see what we have done
is yeah, we have imported this Matplotlib library
and we have selected a particular class
from that library that is Pyplot.
Probably you have used this earlier
for plotting different graphs
and we are representing that particular class as PLT.
So this is the naming convention that we'll use
and that we naturally use in Python libraries.
And we have represented this X and Y
as the two different attributes.
As we have already discussed.
So these X and Y are nothing but the value of the subjects
that we get for each of the students.
So this is the entire length of the dataset.
So this is a list of X basically for subject one.
Y is a list for subject two.
And for example, for student one
we'll see the index one of X and Y.
Similarly for student two we'll see the index of this X two
and this Y, right?
And what we are going to plot now
we're going to do a scatter plot.
As we discussed the students here will be the data points
and this X and Y the subjects will represent
each of the attribute.
Now let's just do the scatter plot.
I assume that you are in the same time
using that notebook that we have shared
and you are running the code in your own system
that will make the entire process much more interesting.
And if you are having any questions
we'll have a good discussion regarding those.
So you see once we plot the data points that we earlier had
it looks something like this.
Still now we don't have a problem statement
because I haven't shared any problem statement
just to give you an basic idea.
Now if we have this kind of dataset
what conclusion we can come?
So here you see there are this ranges basically
for the X axis and the Y axis.
Let's say from four to 14 and from 14 to 24.
So what does this represent?
This represent the subjects, right?
Now what are this data could mean in real life?
This could mean the student marks for a particular subject.
So this X represent for a particular subject
what the marks the students get
and for the Y also it represents
this for the subject to what the students got.
Now this graph represents two clear divisions of students.
These black points are nothing but students, right?
So if there is a distinction between the students
then what conclusion we can draw?
We can draw that there are some students
who got good marks in both the subjects.
There are students who got bad marks on both the subjects
and there are students who got almost like
average kind of marks.
So this is what this particular graph represent
this scatter plot represents.
Now if we have the information
if we can see this graph properly
as a human being it's quite easy for us to distinguish
between these two groups.
So for example, this will be one group in the top corner
this will be one group
where we can call as the best students
of this particular session.
And these are the worst students or bad students
who were not able to perform well in these two subjects.
So this is very easy to understand for us
because we are able to see
this graphical representation of scatter plot.
Now how a model, a computational model can understand this?
So that's where the concept play
of the K-means clustering algorithm.
We'll see that if we implement
the K-means clustering algorithm for this data set
whether it will be able to cluster these two sets.
But before proceeding just I am going to show you
what the particular question was previously.
So this was the question that we were working on.
So let's take an example with marks of 22 students.
So there are 22 different data points for two subjects.
And the problem is also given here
which is to find the group of excellent
and underperforming students.
So here you see that is now clear
because the problem is given.
But even with the problem not given to you
and if you have a basic understanding of the data set
you can curate the problem by yourself.
In real life data analytics actually involves
creating your problem and then solving it in real life.
So if you get a data set randomly
you see what is the data set.
You get different statistics of it.
You understand the data set.
You create the problem and then you solve it.
So let's just see if we can use
the K-means clustering algorithm
to actually solve this problem.
Now before going to this K-means clustering algorithm
you have to understand what is the SQL learn
and what is this cluster thing means.
So SQL learn is the library and cluster is one class
and with that class there will be a subclass.
The name of the subclass is K-means.
So this SQL learn library you can go to Google
and search for this SQL learn library.
I'm just going to show you here.
So if you go to this SQL learn library
which is known as the scikit learn.
So if you are going to install it via pip
you have to write pip install scikit-learn
then it will install that particular module or library.
So here you see there are different modules
in the left hand section where you can navigate
and you have these sections for supervised learning methods
and the unsupervised learning methods.
And since we are going to work on the clustering aspect
we have just swept to this clustering method.
And here you will see a very good information
about clustering algorithms.
Probably we will not be able to cover all the aspects
that is present here but I will be able to give you
a general idea by which you can follow this
and you can follow the entire clustering thing
and you can have a good idea of it.
So I think this is the library.
Once you are working with a library
it is always a good idea to go to that library
and see what the developers has written for you.
It will give you a good understanding
of the different functions that are present here, right?
So here for example, there are different methods
like k-means, affinity propagation
and there are lots and lots of algorithms
already implemented for you.
And today we will be working with this k-means things.
Probably you have gone through the theoretical aspect
so I'm not going deep dive into this.
So let's go to the coding section one again
and we are importing this k-means library
as you can see here in the selection.
So this k-means library once you have that
it is basically an object of k-means
that you can use to cluster.
And the code is very, very simple.
I think you can just type from the screen
or you can just copy and paste from the notebook
whatever suits you.
Now I'm just creating a variable,
the name of the variable is k-means
and I am just using that object k-means
and giving few parameters.
And the most important parameter here is the n clusters.
This is a requirement for this k-means clustering algorithm.
So you will require to give this n clusters values,
basically the number of clusters
before you can even start the clustering algorithm.
So you have to have some idea about the dataset beforehand
that maybe in my dataset
there could be a maximum of three clusters.
So I'll put the value of n equals to three.
So with this dataset that we were working on
we see that the number of clusters will be two
because we have already done a scatter plot
and we see that there are two distinguishable classes.
Now let's just change that value from four to two
as simple as that.
And there is another parameter here
which is known as n init.
So n init is a parameter which is set to auto for now
which is by default it is auto.
So the n init is actually a parameter
that is used to initialize the number of times
the centroids of the algorithm.
So if you understand the actual algorithm how it works
it actually randomly initializes the centroids.
So if the n clusters is two
then it will initialize two centroids randomly
in any location in the data point, the dataset.
Then it will optimize it to the correct place
to get the k-means clustering algorithm working.
But this n init actually decides
that how many number of initializations will happen.
Basically if we randomly initialize with each initialization
there is a possibility that we get some different clusters.
That's why there is this hyper parameter
and this is a quite important parameter.
That's why I've given there are some more parameters
that we are not going to discuss.
So if this n init is selected as auto
it will select that maybe there are 11 times
of initializations required and it will select
the base clusters when all the initializations are done.
So it will initialize for example 10 times.
So it will run the k-means algorithm 10 times
and find the optimal values from there.
So once we have this done, so this is basically
you initialize the object of k-means.
You initialize an object of k-means.
And the object here refers to the two clusters
and initialized with n init as auto.
And then we will see that the very simple function fit
is used to fit our data.
And what is our data?
I think we have not discussed this yet.
So this part is also very important.
So the data we had earlier is basically two lists
of x and y, basically two lists of the subjects,
basically marks of the subjects.
But now we want this data to be handled
in a single zip find.
So in a single list, right?
So it will be a list of list, nested list.
So if that is the case, how we can do that?
It's very simple.
If you know Python, it's like a one liner code
where you zip this two list
and then again convert it to a list.
So this zip function takes the two different lists
that we are providing x and y.
And then we are again converting that particular zip
to another list.
And we are going to print this data
and let's see how this data looks now.
So you see right now we have a list
which contains the different features together.
So this is the feature one, five,
and this is the another feature 15 for the student one.
So this is the feature for student one.
This is the feature for student two.
This is the feature for student three and so on.
And we have for this first feature,
these two features for student one,
which represents the data point that we have plotted here.
Quite simple to understand, right?
So once we have this data,
a little bit of just pre-processing we can say,
and we can just give it as an input directly to this,
came in algorithm fit function.
So fit takes the data that you have,
the raw data, numerical data that you have.
And once you give this numerical data to the fit,
you can expect this K-means clustering algorithm
to output the labels.
We have discussed this that the labels are generally
the classes or the groups that the model has identified.
And the labels here that are generated
are basically started from zero and like any positive values.
And this represents a particular group.
So zero will represent one group,
one will represent another group that we'll see.
So let's consider this.
So we will run this code and we will print the value of C.
C will contain the clusters,
the basically least of the clusters.
So we will have, you can see there are 22 data points
and each of this 22 data points,
which are basically 22 students,
has been represented into a list of zeros and ones.
Why zeros and ones?
Because we have already selected
that there will be only two clusters,
n clusters is selected as two.
That's why it will be zero and one.
So zero is one group, one is another group.
Now let's see if we have been able to properly replicate
what we were able to see in the plot.
So we, for that we need to visualize the clusters.
It is also quite simple.
So these codes are very, very simple.
You can just grab this code and use it anywhere as you like.
And once you are having this class completed,
I think you will be able to work
on any clustering algorithm dataset,
regardless of the size and the originality of the dataset.
So let's consider this where we are just going to plot
this graph again, scatter plot this graph again.
But this time we are just color representing
each of this data point based on the levels
that we have formulated.
So this K-means levels as you can understand
is the output basically the C.
And we are going to plot this scatter plot
and let's see what is the output that we get.
So this is the output that we get.
I think you can see this properly.
So here we have this two data points,
these two axis of the graph.
And these two different groups have been properly identified
without any issue.
Because you know this is a simple problem that I have given
for understanding of the algorithm from your aspect.
So as you can see that this is a graph
of these two data points which has been properly identified
by this K-means clustering algorithm.
And since we were able to see using the scatter plot
that there are two groups we were able to give
the number of clusters as two properly.
But if we somehow were not able to give this number
of clusters properly there could be some issues.
And that we will check.
Now if this is a truly good cluster
then probably the evaluation scores should be higher.
Previously probably you have heard about evaluation
of classification methods where you have a metric like
F1 score, you have a metric like accuracy.
But here we don't have metrics like that
because we don't have the ground truth levels
most of the time.
And why I have told most of the time that we'll see.
But if you have this information with you
I think we can go ahead with this
and we can see how this particular thing works.
So we will evaluate the clusters
while we don't have a ground truth.
So this is the siloity coefficient.
This is a very, very important metric
that we use to understand the quality of clusters.
You can go through this particular documentation
that I have given here.
But the most important thing that you will require
is present here.
So the score of this siloity coefficient
is bounded between minus one for incorrect clustering
and plus one for highly dense clustering.
Scores around zero indicate overlapping clusters.
So this is the most important aspect
of this evaluation metric that you will come across.
So if you just run this clustering evaluation technique
for the data that we have used,
we will see that we'll get a value
between minus one and plus one.
It will range between minus one and plus one.
And plus one means our algorithm is very, very good.
And minus one means it is doing incorrect kind of clustering.
Around zero, it is overlapping clusters.
So what are overlapping clusters?
That also we will see, we will discuss.
So generally it means that we want a score
which is very, very close to plus one.
So since this method we have used
and we see that the algorithm was able to cluster
all the points properly.
So we expect the value to be very, very close to one, right?
So let's see how we can implement
this like evaluation metric.
So from SCALARN, import metrics.
This is a very simple like class
that actually gives you all the metrics
that are present in the SCALARN library.
And what we want is from this SCALARN library,
from the metrics class, we want this CELOTIS score.
And the CELOTIS scores take three different parameters.
As you can see, the first parameter is the data.
And the data is already we have created.
We have shown how we have created the zip
of these two different, different like attributes.
And we have this C which is basically the cluster name
that has been generated by the K-means model.
And then the metric, metric is basically,
it creates the distance between this data point
and the cluster.
So this is an distance-based metric
and we are selecting as a plurian-based distance.
So these are the different parameters.
And if we run this, we will end up with a value
of the score that we get.
And we see that we get a score of 0.72145.
So it is very, very close to one.
Now you may ask that why it is not exactly one.
It is not exactly one,
even if the clustering is 100% correct,
is because this is an error kind of metric.
So Silo T score determines the error
in your particular clustering algorithm.
Error can be low, but it cannot be zero
because you don't have the particular original levels
associated.
If you had these levels properly with you,
then you could have used some other metric
that use these levels and you could get a score
which is very, very close to one.
So this gives you an idea of error in your model
and the error, if it is very, very close to one,
that means the error to your model is very, very low.
So 0.7214, right?
So just keep a note of here.
0.712, 0.717215.
So this is the score that we get
if we give the value of K as two, right?
So in this, you can see that since we have used
the clustering algorithm and we were able
to identify the K equals to two,
now you can determine if we select the K equals to three
or K equals to four, what could happen?
Generally, this value, this Silo T score
or Silo T coefficient will decrease
if we increase the value of K
because it will make the cluster wrong, right?
So let's see there is another metric known as CH index.
I'm not going through the definition here,
but the only thing that is most important here
is that the score is higher when the clusters are dense
and well-separated, which relates
to a standard concept of clusters.
So here also we want a higher score
and what is the upper limit?
We are not sure about it, but we have this score
and generally we can normalize most of the time, the score,
but the higher the score, the better one.
So let's run this same thing.
So it is very, very similar to the previous one,
just here you don't have to give any specific metric
on the distance that we are going to use.
So I'm just running this CH index in a similar way
and see that we get a positive value of 1 to 1.28.
So I'm just writing it here.
So 1 to 1.29, so this is for the value of K equals to 2.
This is for the value of K equals to 2.
There is another metric, which is also quite important.
So it is also known as DB index.
So DB index, so the zero is the lowest possible value
and values closer to zero now indicate a better partition.
So this is also very, very significant thing
that we need to know.
And other things like we are not discussing at this moment.
So if you are going to use this metric,
you will see that this DB index can be initialized
using this particular line of code.
And it also takes these two parameters
like all the other methods.
And we can run this and you'll see that you get a value
which is 0.38.
So we get a value of 0.3819.
And this is the value we can call very, very close to zero.
So as we go on increasing,
so you'll see that the value is getting increased.
So let's see for in real life.
Let's see if we change the value of K equals to,
let's say three, what happens?
So here we initialize the cluster.
Now instead of taking the n cluster is equal to two,
let's see what happens if we take the value of K equals to three.
So let's say we don't know what is the actual value of K
for now, K is basically the number of clusters.
So let's run this, we'll have a new set of values.
You can see two is present here, so zero, one and two.
So these are the three groups.
And let's again visualize the cluster using the same code.
Let's visualize the cluster.
And here you'll see that now we have clusters data
and it looks something like this.
So this part is one part of the cluster,
one group of the cluster.
This is the second group of the cluster,
this is the second group, and this is the third group.
So somehow the clustering algorithm was able to identify
that this could be one of the group, right?
So if these are the different groups,
the model has been identified.
So from our visualization, we can see
that this is not a very good grouping.
So it should actually lower the evaluation metrics
in their own aspect.
So let's see what is the CDT score we get.
So it is 0.5227, so 0.5227, right?
So you see that we from K equals to two
where we had 0.7215, we had 0.7215,
we are now left with 0.5227 for K equals to three.
Let's see what is happening with CH index.
So here as you can understand a higher score is better, right?
So let's see, we get a 77.85.
So 77.85 for K equals to three.
And for DB index also we get,
let's say we run this code again
and we get 0.67, 0.6713 for the K value of three.
So you can see that this metric is actually good
if it is closer to zero.
And now it is moving apart from zero.
So basically the clustering is degraded,
the quality of the clustering is degraded.
So this is the way that you can use to identify
if your clustering algorithm is proper or not.
So all this algorithm takes the data
and the different clusters.
And it measures the error distance as you can understand.
So all of these are error that are being represented
into different normalized form for easy understanding, right?
So this is a very important part of this algorithm
because if you know this part properly,
you will be able to handle all the things
that will come next in this particular class.
So now we are going to discuss another aspect of this.
Let's just grab this where we have.
So we were dealing with this data set, as you can understand.
We were dealing with this data set
where we had this x data points
and we have this o data points.
These are quite easy for the clustering algorithm to work on.
And since this is only a parameter of x and y, x and y,
where x represented basically the subject one
and y represented the subject two.
So each of these points, each of these points
will have two different sets.
So x one and y one, for example.
So these are these we call as the feature representation, right?
So if this feature representation is increased,
so if we have multiple features, right?
So we had only two features here,
so which is very, very easy to understand.
But you can understand in real life,
we don't have that many number of features.
So in real life, probably we will end up with a data set
that will have this x values and o values.
And of course we will not know which is x and which is o,
but still this kind of values will be represented
with many, many number of parameters.
So let's say the parameter will be a one,
a two, a three, and so on.
If there are, for example, a n features.
So if there are n dimensional features available to you,
there will be this x which will be represented
by this n number of features.
Why this is important?
Because in real life, you will not end up having only
two features, but we'll end up with multiple features
for a single data point.
So it is very easy.
As you can understand, we had this x values and y values
together.
And once we had this x value and y values,
we zipped them together into a single list.
And we can do the same thing for all type of dimensions.
If the dimensions are increased in real life,
we can work on that also, right?
So we were talking about overlapping clusters previously.
So when the CELOTI coefficient becomes zero,
that means the clusters are overlapping.
Now K means algorithm works by selecting
the different means.
So for example, if we have selected the mean in this
position, this position, particular position,
and we selected another mean, let's say a blue mean
in this position.
So generally, the class will be determined
by this green class, which will be represented like this,
and the blue class, which will be represented like this.
So basically, these are kind of like circular kind
of representations that actually distinguishes
between the different groups that you are going to cluster.
But you can understand if we have a data point.
So if we consider a data point, let's say
we have this data point where we have this x here and this O
here, then how is it possible for you to cluster?
Because there will be two centroids,
because we have selected the value of K equals to 2.
And you can see that the centroids will lie somewhere here.
The two different centroids will lie somewhere here.
So let's consider these two centroids.
One is pink, one is blue.
And they will not be able to cluster this properly.
They will not be able to cluster this properly,
because their centroids are same.
This is the centroid-based algorithm.
So here, the clustering algorithm will only
work if the clusters are non-overlapping.
So this is the idea of overlapping.
So you don't want these means to be together.
You want these means to be separated,
just like the previous case or the example
that we were already observing.
So if this kind of data set we are having,
then K means clustering works wonders.
So this is how you can understand which particular algorithm
you can select for a particular data set,
if you know the idea behind how the model works.
Now again, let's go to the code.
So we have seen till now that by changing the value of K,
we can understand using different evaluation metrics
that which particular value of K we can be selecting.
But that is a very inefficient way of selecting the value of K.
Instead of that, there is another way
that we can use to actually approximate the value of K.
This we don't use regularly.
It is not guaranteed to give you good value of K
or correct value of K, regardless,
that gives us an understanding of where
the particular value of K may lie.
So for that, we need to use something
known as the ELBO method.
So we will see that how this particular thing works
is that from the cluster we are again initializing this K means.
And in this data, we are again taking
the list of this X and Y, which is again the same data
that we have already used.
There's nothing new here.
And then there is another list that we
are creating, which is an empty list for now.
And it will capture the sum of squared errors
for all these clusters.
So sum of squared errors are nothing but the errors,
basically the distance from the actual cluster center.
So if the centroid is known to you,
you can just calculate its error.
But this thing is very, very easy to understand
if you have gone through this algorithm theory aspect.
So basically, we are getting the sum of squared errors
or within cluster sum of squared errors, whatever
may be the case.
And now we are having this loop for all the 11 times.
So what is this 1 to 11?
It's basically how many number of times
we are going to check for the value of K.
So this is nothing but the value of K.
So till like 1 to 11, we are going to check.
I think this is quite easy to understand.
So these are the number of values of K
that we are going to check.
And then from that value, we are going
to select a particular value of K that is a good value.
Now how do we know that a particular value is good?
Let's see that.
So here we are again initializing the K-means clustering
algorithm.
But now the n clusters will be initialized by i.
What is i?
It is the iterate that is ranging between 1 and 11.
And n in it is again auto.
We are not going to change that parameter at all for now.
So this is how we are setting up our algorithm.
We are then going to fit the data that we have created.
This is the exact same data that we were working on.
And the K-means.fit actually does it for you.
And then we're going to take the error from the model.
How we are going to take the error from the model?
We are going to take the error by appending this
to the inertia.
And the error is basically K-means.inertia.
So this will give you an error value for the model.
This is something that the model calculates by itself.
This is a sum of squared error that model is optimizing for.
So once you have this, we can store this
in this inertia list.
So this inertia list is being appended
by all the errors for clustering value of K equals to 1,
K equals to 2, K equals to 3, K equals to 4, and so on.
So there is one thing.
Like if the value of K equals to 1,
what is going to happen?
What is going to happen?
We can see that all.
So we are just going to print the inertials for now.
Inertials are the error.
So we see that we get a set of values for inertia.
So these are the set of inertial values
for basically all the errors.
Now what we are going to do is we are going to plot this.
It's very, very easy to plot this list.
So we are going to plot between the range of 1 and 11
because we are having this 11 points, 11 Ks.
And we are having this, basically 10 Ks.
And we are having this inertial, which is the error.
And we are giving a marker O so that this is just
for visualization.
We are giving the title and the x label and the y label.
So x label here is the number of clusters,
which is determined by the value of K.
And this y label is basically the sum of squared errors.
Now we can just run this code.
And we'll see that we'll end up with a graph
that looks like this, the graph that looks like this.
So for one, it is very, very high, right?
One, it is very, very high.
The within cluster sum of squared errors.
But as we go on this side, it is getting less.
So the error is getting less.
Now we will see that a lesser number of error is good, right?
But in reality, like a less error doesn't mean good.
Because these are clustering algorithms.
The errors will go on getting less if you increase
the number of clusters.
Because those will try to overfit.
If you know the term overfit, you are trying to fit
most of the data points, right?
So for example, you have 10 data points
and you have 10 clusters.
Each cluster will be represented by one group.
It will be highly overfitting.
But there you will see that the error will be very, very less.
But we don't want error to be the least.
But rather, we want a portion of the error
where we see a good change in the error.
So what we are observing here is the change in error.
Here we are seeing the change in within cluster sum of squared errors.
So here you see that we found an increasing value
at this stage of 2, where the value of k equals 2.
Before that, it is very high.
And then it's dipping in a very low fashion.
So this value of 2 can be selected as the value of k
in our algorithm.
So this is how we can determine the k value.
And this method is known as the ELBO method.
Because we are trying to find an ELBO
where we see a maximum deviation of this error, right?
So this ELBO method, as I told you,
can be used to find the value of k,
but it's not that much reliable, but can be used in many cases.
To actually give you a better idea,
like which out of maybe five values which I can select.
Now let's just change this to the k value of 2 and 11.
At the same code, nothing is changed.
Only the change is that we are going
to see that if we can use the evaluation
matrix that we have used earlier.
Because we were seeing that if we change the value of k,
the evaluation matrix also changed.
And the evaluation matrix are nothing but actually calculating
the error by itself.
There is the sum of squared error from the model
that you get.
And here we are giving, for example,
Euclidean distance to measure this error function,
or error distance.
So here, for example, for the value
of i in the range of 2 and 11, we
find that if we get these kind of values where
we have this 2, 11, and now instead of giving the error
values as inertials that we earlier did,
instead of that we are just giving the values of CELOTI score.
We are directly giving the CELOTI score to this inertia.
We're just storing it.
And CELOTI score, as we have already discussed,
that it takes data, the C parameter,
which is basically the different classes or clusters,
and this metric, which is the distance that it
is going to calculate there.
And then we are going to print this inertia again just to see.
So we have this value.
Now again, plot this.
I'm not explaining the code.
It's the same code.
Nothing changed.
So here also we will see that if we take this,
we get the highest amount of value in 2.
Now you will see that we cannot select inertials from 1.
The range will be from 2 because the clustering algorithms
always expect that there will be at least two clusters.
So you cannot give the value which is less than 2.
So here you see that we get the highest value at 7.
Now what this CELOTI coefficient tells?
It ranges from minus 1 to plus 1.
Plus 1 is the best score that you can get, anything
that is near to plus 1.
Minus 1 is the worst case that you can get.
And around 0 it is an overlapping cluster,
which is also not good, or that is also what we don't want.
So here you see that we directly get,
by using CELOTI score, a similar kind of thing
that we get from an ELBO method.
But here we are not finding the ELBO.
We are finding the maximum value, which is more than 0.7.
So maybe 0.7, 0.73 or something like that.
And this represents to the cluster number 2.
So using this method also we can see
that the cluster that we need to select is determined.
So this is also the two clusters.
So I think this is the part that we were discussing.
This is an important aspect.
If you are able to understand this,
the next part will be very, very easy.
We'll work with some real-life data set,
some high-dimensional data set also.
So any question that you are having, just keep it with you.
We can discuss it in the question answering session.
So this is another data set.
I will just go through it fast, because we
don't need to understand this more.
But let's again consider another example.
So now here we are scatterplot this particular data set
that we have created.
You will get the same in your notebook also.
And here you can see the number of clusters
are three that we can understand.
Now let's consider n equals 2c and what happens.
We can just run it.
And we'll see that we get three clusters.
We can just plot them.
And we'll see that this is also very easy for the K-means
clustering algorithm to work on again.
So if there are no overlapping clusters
and the clusters are well separated,
most of the algorithms that we'll work on
will be able to solve that problem.
The issue will arise when in real-life data
you will have clusters which are very, very close together
or which are overlapping.
So if there is overlapping, you have
to understand how you can detect this overlapping.
And you can actually omit using this K-means algorithm
at all for those kind of data.
So there are other algorithms that you can prefer in that case.
So these are the, again, different metrics
that we are going to run.
And you will see that we are getting a very close value
to 1 plus 1.
For ch index, we are getting a higher value.
For db index, we are getting a value which is close to 0.
So this all indicates that the clustering is good.
So this is how you can understand the quality of clustering.
It's very, very easy to understand.
Now, again, we are seeing that if we write down the elbow
method here, what we get.
So here you will see, again, the elbow method,
that we get a very good deep from here.
But we don't form an elbow at this position now.
For the previous one, we were getting an elbow at this position.
But now we are getting an elbow in this position.
From here, you see that the error does not deviate much.
But for this part, we can select that the particular values of K
could be either 2 or 3.
But 3 will be a more reasonable choice
because we found an elbow at 3.
And we see that the actual value is 3 here.
So this works for most of the data points that work.
But in real life, this doesn't work that great.
Basically, this you can use for sampling the values of K.
You can select some samples.
And then you can actually apply the algorithm.
Because in real life, you cannot apply these many times
all the values.
It will be very, very difficult.
So there are different sampling and things
required to actually achieve this in real life data set.
So there is another data set where
we have a scattered kind of data points now.
Now we don't have a very significant clusters or groups
of data.
And let's see what happens if we just
run this through this elbow method now.
Because we first want to identify that if the elbow
method is working properly or not.
Here again, we'll see that you find an elbow at 2.
It's quite obvious.
So we select the value of clusters as 2.
And then we again run the algorithm.
We get the clusters.
And we draw the scatter plot.
And it is again still able to find
that this is one cluster and that is another cluster, which
again corresponds to some of the aspects
that we were already looking for.
So these are the two subjects for the students.
And the excellent students are highlighted in yellow.
And average students and the lower grade students
are marked by violet.
So this is how the algorithm actually works.
I think this is quite easy for you to understand.
And this yellow marking is what does that
mean that you have to identify afterwards,
after you run the algorithm.
So yellow are the excellent and then underperforming
are the violets that you have to determine
once you run the algorithm.
Again, we can just measure the sellout coefficient, which
is 0.5417.
This is quite normal, because it's
near about plus 1, which is not closer to 0.
So now we will see a different part
that we were already discussing, that we have multiple attributes.
Instead of only two attributes, we have now three attributes.
This is a three dimensional dataset
that we are working on.
So let's just see.
So this is another changes.
So we are not dealing with much of the things.
We are just keeping the labels here.
So we are keeping this list of x, y, and z.
So these are the three dimensions.
So for student one, since we were discussing about student,
student one, this is one score, this is another score,
and this is another score.
So x, y, z represent different subjects here.
So now, instead of two subjects, we have three subjects.
And I think that should be clear enough.
Now we are going to plot this 3D graph.
So for 3D graph, we are using an imperial toolkit,
this library.
It provides an easy to understand,
like how you can just plot in 3D projections.
And this, you can see that it's important to implore 3D.
This is the class and object that we are going to use.
I think, like we have not used this, whatever.
So that won't be an issue.
So we are not using this particular 3D thing.
We are just using the PLT basically, the matplotlib libraries
3D function.
And we are just plotting this axis.
And we are setting the projection to be 3D, 3D projection.
And this axis value actually contains
the axis of the new generated plots.
And there, we can plot the different values.
And the data that we will want to, we can plot it there.
So the data it will take, it will take three different data.
Because it is a three-dimensional graph.
It takes x, y, and z values.
And we are giving the graph color to be green.
So all the points here, the scatter will be green color.
Let's see if we run this code what we get.
So we get something like this.
So in this 3D space, you can see this
is how the data are arranged.
Now, it was quite easy for us to understand in the 2D case
that there are these two clusters, there are three clusters.
But as you see, just increasing only one dimension
makes the thing much more difficult for us to visualize,
as well as to represent the number of values of k.
Now, if I ask you what is the value of k here,
probably you will starter and you will not
be able to give, because this is the reality.
And in our real life, we will not have three data points.
Or basically, we will not have these three attributes.
There will be hundreds of attributes
that we'll be working on.
And visualization of those number of attributes
is impossible.
So we have to understand that.
So everything that we need to do is
we have to use the values that we are getting
from this evaluation matrix or the error functions
that we have to understand to understand how a model works.
For general understanding, the thing
that we discussed was very, very important.
But in reality, if you go through this in your real life,
you'll see that we were not able to determine these values
that we will be able to do for the 2D cases.
So again, the things are very easy.
That is the thing.
So even if this is very, very difficult for you
to find visually that what will be the number of clusters,
but the algorithms are there for us.
And we know the algorithms.
So here you'll see that we'll again
import this K-means clustering algorithm.
And we will save this data into this zip,
where now we are zipping this x, y, and z value together.
And if you have multiple attributes,
let's say you have 100 of attributes.
It's very, very simple.
You just give x1, x2, x3, till x100.
So there will be this 100 list of attributes
that you zip and make a list of it.
In that case, you will have for each data
100 of different features.
Again, we are giving this inertia.
And this we are going to run this basically this ELBO method.
And we are trying to find out what
could be the reasonable value of K
to select for this particular thing.
If we run this, you will see that we get this kind of value.
So here you will see that the ELBO is formed at 4.
The ELBO is formed around at 4.
Because after that, we don't see much of a deviation.
And before that, the decrement in the error is very high.
So this 4 could be one of our choices.
So we can select multiple samples from here.
And then we can run the algorithm and see
what could be the cellotic coefficient on others.
So let's consider that number of clusters to be 4.
Let's consider the number of clusters to be 4.
And run this algorithm.
Same, we are not doing anything extra.
You can see that there are these three clusters.
And we can just plot this again.
And we'll see that we now end up with these three different
clusters, four different clusters.
So here this blue cluster represents one of the clusters.
This yellow represents one of the clusters.
This green represents one of the clusters.
And this violet represents another cluster.
So you see that using this value of k and by coloring,
now it becomes quite obvious that yes, this
could be a very good value of k.
Because you can understand the values for this
are very, very higher.
These are very, very higher for a different dimension.
These are in the same dimension, but these are far apart.
So this is how you can see that these algorithms work.
So this is very, very interesting to find out.
And then again, we can use the same evaluation
criteria that we had.
And you can see that you will get the score from there.
And if you change the values of again k,
and you can have a different identification
of what particular values you might need for a better
clustering algorithm.
So this is the general idea.
Now we will move up to--
so I think what you can do here is,
since we'll have this notebook, you
can change the value of k for all the cases
and see how this 3D case changes, and how
the difference velocity scores and CH index or dB index
changes as per those values, so that you
can have a clear understanding.
Now we will move up to next phase of our hands-on,
where we will discuss about real-life data sets.
So let's reconnect this.
So for this part, we'll be using this housing.csv data
set.
I'm just going to open this data set for you once.
So this is the housing data set.
So you see that there is no label associated
with this data set.
And we have different attributes made in house edge,
ab homes, ab bedrooms, and so on.
So there are different attributes present here.
I think you can go and check this data set.
It is the data set of numerical values.
I don't see any other kind of values.
So all the values are numerical values.
So we don't have to do any kind of preprocessing here.
If there are no numerical values,
you must understand that these models actually
work on numerical values.
So you have to convert them to numbers.
So this is the data set that we'll be working on.
So how do we import this data set is very easy.
We're going to mount this Google Drive,
because my data is stored in my Google Drive.
If you're writing the code locally,
you can just download this data set
and just use this pandas to actually load it.
So now we have mounted the drive.
You have to mount the drive using this particular command
drive.mount.
And you can just give the location
where you want to mount the drive.
And then what we want is we want to import
the data set into our notebook.
For that, we want to import the library of pandas
that is used for this values
and storage of structured data.
So pd.readcsv gives you the functionality
where you can just give the location of the file.
The file location in my case is drive
plus my drive plus housing.csv.
And then you can see that we can load that in x.
And we can just give x.head,
which gives you five first values present in the data frame.
So this is what we were observing in the original data set.
It's nothing but the same thing.
So we end up with this data in our notebook.
Now what we want is we want to see
that if we are able to do the exact same thing
that we did earlier, right?
So let's see.
So we have stored this value in x.
So x is the data frame that we have used, right?
So right now, we are just considering
three different attributes
because we have already done work with the 3D data, right?
So just let's see if we give these three attributes,
made ink, houses, and abhomes,
and can we make the clusters?
By changing nothing in the code.
So basically what we were doing earlier,
we are doing the exact same thing.
We're not changing anything.
We're just taking the data from the pandas data frame.
That's it.
To take the column of x,
so made ink from x,
x which is basically the data frame.
So made ink is basically the column, this one, right?
And these are the different feature values.
And this is a featured name.
And for made ink,
so this column we are adopting.
For houses also we are adopting.
This and for abhomes we are adopting.
And you see that we can make the list of these data sets
similar to the previous one.
Again, we are going to run these energias
again to plot the value of basically elbow method.
Now you see that it becomes difficult.
It becomes difficult to find a very good value of elbow
because there is no particular elbow
that we find here that satisfied properly.
So one could be like the value of could be two.
And another could be three.
So two and three are quite similar.
So there is no distinct manner.
So two and three we can try out.
So again, we use this claymines clustering algorithm.
Nothing changed.
Only we are using this to feed the data
that we have created, right?
And we are storing that into C2.
So now the variable name is changed to C2.
And we are just running this.
And again for the cluster three,
we are storing the value to C3.
And nothing is changed.
So the K value of two is stored in C2,
K value of three is stored in C3.
Now we want to measure the valuation for C2 and C3.
So for CELOT score,
let's see the value for C2 and C3.
What do we get?
So for C2, we got 5590, right?
And for C3, we get 5146.
So you see from this CELOT score,
C2 seems to be much more good
because it is closer to one.
And 51 is less than 55.
So C2, where the K value is two,
seems to be a much good model according to CELOT.
Okay.
Now we are going to understand about feature extraction.
Why this is important?
Because you see, we have so many features.
We have, let's say in this dataset also,
we have multiple features around 10, 12 features we have.
And if you want to give all these features to the model,
the model might be not be able to perform well.
Why? Because there might be some repetitive,
basically features.
There might be some features which are not important.
There might be some features which we don't need, right?
So we can omit those features directly if we don't need.
That we call as feature selection method.
In feature selection method,
if you already know that I need this data,
I need this data and I don't need rest of the data
that we did in the previous case.
So here you see, I have just given this three column name.
That means that I want these three column features
to be issued and rest I don't want.
So this is a feature selection process.
I selected mating, house age and abhome.
And I removed all the others.
So this is feature selection.
But feature selection doesn't always work good
because you might not know which feature
and that is very difficult
because you have to understand the domain
to know that which feature to keep
and which feature to remove.
So in real life, we'll end up having
to use feature extraction method more
than feature selection in many of the cases.
So what is feature extraction?
Feature extraction does a very opposite thing
but to feature selection.
In feature extraction, you have multiple features.
Let's say you have five features
and you want to create three new features
which actually represents these five features.
So you want to reduce the dimension of features.
So you want to keep the information of all the five features
but you are reducing its dimension to three features.
Of course, some information will be lost
but most of the information will be there
because we have seen that these methods,
these feature extraction methods,
if you use it wisely, they will be performing very well
and it will take less resources
because it was at the end of the day
giving less number of features to the model.
You're passing less number of features to the model.
So here you will see that how we can do this.
So first we have to normalize.
Normalization is very easy, it's a simple code
where we normalize the X.
X is nothing but all the values
that are present in our dataset
and we are going to normalize it
by the minimum and the maximum value.
So this is known as the mean max normalization.
It's very easy.
So this is the line of the code that is required
and once we normalize this, we store it in X norm.
If you want to see, we can just,
we can just run this separately
and we can just print this X norm.
So you see this is the X norm.
Okay, let's just print the head.
Two values.
So head.2 gives you the first two,
first two rows of the data frame, right?
And I will also print this value
which is the X.head2, which gives me the value.
So you can see this was the original value 8.3252
and after normalization it becomes 0.5368.
So this is the change that we get after normalization.
So we normalize the entire data frame.
This is not recommended
that you normalize the entire data frame by mean max.
It is something like that you have to understand
that when we use this and we don't use this.
So once we have this X normalized
and now we can generate this PCA.
PCA is a principal component analysis.
This is basically a feature extraction method.
This is widely used probably you have heard of this
in the machine learning class.
Also probably you have heard of this to reduce
the number of features.
I'm not going to explain that
but this Escaline library again gives you the class
for this PCA and the object for this PCA
for you to work on very easily.
You can just create the object PCA
by using one hyper parameter.
The hyper parameter is the N component.
It is the number of features that you are going to convert.
So you can see we have many, many features, right?
We have like several number of features in this list
in this data frame.
But out of that, I only wanted two features.
So it will convert all these features,
let's attain features into these two features lower dimension.
You see that if you are converting such a higher dimension
data to a lower dimension,
you are going to compromise a lot
because you are going to lose huge amount of data.
This is not really expected
but for showing you that this works and how it works,
this is the example that I've taken.
So once you have this PCA,
you see that this PCA component can be used
to fit transform this X normalized version
of this data frame or data that we are using.
So for that, you can see this part of the code,
this part of the code where we are fitting this X norm data
that we have shown normalized version of the data
into this PCA object.
And it creates a normalized version of it.
And then we are creating this transformed version
and converting it to a data frame once again.
So this transformed version,
let's print this transformed version
to see what happens here.
So this is the transformed version.
Now you see in the transformed version,
we have only two columns,
basically two features, zero and one.
And all the feature values are represented
for each of the data.
So there were like 20640 rows of data.
So we were able to compress this dimension of data,
so higher dimension of data into a two dimension data.
Now it's expected that since we are reducing
so much dimension, we will lose up some information.
So the clustering won't be good.
So you have to select wisely the number of components
and which components you want to basically reduce
the dimension of.
So not all the features might not be required
for you to reduce the dimension.
So once we have this, let's just get to the next step
where we will now work with the transformed version
of the data.
We were working with the inter dataset,
we transformed it and now we'll work on this data
and let's plot this and you'll see
that we'll get this kind of plot.
This is just to show you that the plots are very, very,
like getting something which we cannot work on.
Even if this is a two dimensional data,
you can see that most of the data points
that are present here is very, very difficult for us
to judge that which cluster this particular thing belongs to.
The number of data points are very, very high.
And in most of the cases, we'll see that we use
PCA for visualization also.
So if you want to visualize, for example,
high dimensional data, we can just transform it
to a two dimensional data and create a plot.
Even if this doesn't make sense many of the times
because you cannot represent higher dimensional data
into a two dimension, but it gives you in some
of the aspects that what the thing could be.
So similar to that, what we are observing here.
It's not a very good informative thing,
but it's something that we can see to judge.
So let's do the same thing now, again, we'll do.
So now, again, we end up with X and Y, and X and Y
are nothing but this dimension reduced PCA components
of this entire data set.
And we're running the exact same code.
We're not modifying anything in the code, right?
So let's run this.
And you will see that we have got the ELBO method here
and finding ELBO is again difficult.
Finding the ELBO is again difficult.
But yeah, so it could be around four.
Again, it could be around four, three and four,
something like that, maybe four and five.
So yeah, four, five, six, these could be the values
that we can select.
So let's go to this value and go to four.
So nothing is changed in the code.
You will see that we are not able to see
the already different clusters here.
And we can measure the CLOT score.
So since we discussed that it could be four or five or six,
let's see which gives us a good score.
So this is 0.4564, right?
Let's just give two, four and six.
Right?
So we had four, five, six, four.
And this is four, zero, nine, two, so this is reduced.
So four was a better, like, K value, right?
Then again, we can just plot it.
So we see, we divide into these number of clusters.
These clusters look like this.
So it is able to do some work on this dataset,
but this is the data that we get.
So if we select two, probably this will be one cluster.
This left side will be one cluster,
and the right side will be another cluster.
Let's just change it to two and let's see what we get.
We get a value of 0.48, not that great,
but yeah, for visualization, we can see
that how it gets visualized.
You see that the left side is like this,
because the centroid is generated somewhere in this position,
and the centroid for this is somewhere in this position,
which creates this cluster.
So it creates a line basically,
as you can understand it, at this position.
So anything in this side will be in this violet section.
Anything on that side of the line
will be in this yellow section.
So this is the thing.
Again, we can do this evaluation matrix.
And you can run this.
So I think this part is also clear.
Any queries from your end,
you can just have that already from your side.
So now we are going to work with another dataset.
Now this dataset is a little bit different.
And since this is a different dataset,
what we are going to do is we are going to use
some different evaluation metrics also.
Now you see that these evaluation metrics,
when they were built,
they were built by the idea of understanding the errors
in the model for defining a particular class
or group for a particular data point.
But here, how can we evaluate
that these particular methods work properly?
Or even, for example,
this came in clustering works actually.
How we can determine that?
We can determine that using any dataset
that we have the class information for.
So this dataset that we are using is a supervised dataset.
For the clustering algorithm,
we are not going to use this class information.
For only the evaluation purpose,
we will use this class information, right?
So this is quite helpful
if you are building a new clustering algorithm, for example.
If you're building a new clustering algorithm,
you'll probably require this class information
to get a better idea of how much good your algorithm works.
So we have this dataset.
So I'm not showing you the dataset here.
So I'm not going to show you this dataset here.
I'm just going to show it in this notebook.
So this is the data that we have, right?
So the first thing that we have is the class.
It is the label.
But in our case where we are just running this algorithm,
we're not going to use this class information.
We're just going to use any other data point,
any other basically attribute that is present here,
but not the class.
Only for the evaluation, we will use this class.
But in your supervised algorithm,
we have used this class to train a model.
But here there is no training involved
and there is no requirement of this class
in the identification of the clusters.
Apart from that, we just use this class
for evaluation purposes.
There are some evaluation metrics
other than the CLOT score, DB index, H index.
There are some other metrics that takes into account
this class information and then gives you a score.
So let's consider that.
So this is the dataset.
And now we are going to see the unique values
that are present in the class.
So just this is very easy.
So we are just using the unique function
of this data frame pandas library for the class value.
So here you see that there are three classes.
So this gives us a general idea
of the number of K values to select.
Since there are three classes,
we can select the value of K to be three.
I think you can write this code and you can see this.
(audience chattering)
So if we print this class value,
so we will see that this is only the class value.
But why I have done this is because
I want to remove this Y from our main data.
So for that, I want X, that is our original data to be
without the class column.
So this X is something that represents
our entire dataset without the class column.
So it is now again an unsupervised dataset this X.
So for that we are using this log function.
So D is the dataset, the entire dataset.
We are using this log function
and we are taking all the values for the columns
which is not equal to class.
So we are just omitting the class.
And if you print that, you will see
that we have all the values.
So let's say print not print.
Let's say X.head gives us a better representation.
X.head two.
So now you see that we don't have this class anymore.
So we have all the other attributes but not the class.
Now again, we are doing this PCA transformation
for the interset.
And now we are using the in components as three.
So yeah, we can select any number of in components
and there is a different thing
that how you can select the number of components.
So we are selecting the in components.
Nothing is being changed from the previous version.
We are just running it.
And we'll have this transformed version again with us.
Transform version now we'll have three attributes
because we have converted this to three components
of the original data set that we are having.
So these three components that we have
that we will use for our clustering method.
So for that, we see that there is this transfer.
Okay, so we are just plotting these values
because not required at all
because only two dimensions we're plotting.
And this is.
Okay, this is also not required.
Yeah, so this is the part that we need.
So here you see that again,
we are just dipping this three list of data,
three features into this data.
And inertia is again,
we are just going to store the sum of squared errors.
So we are going to run this elbow method once again
to identify the number of clusters.
Okay, so we have not created the X.
Okay, so we have to do that.
We have created the value of X.
And so we get this value.
And you see that we get a clear understanding
of the possible K value.
So for this transformation,
we can say that the data set quite represents well
and we get an elbow at three.
And since our data set originally had three levels,
we can understand that this will be a good method
to be a good particular position of the value of K.
So we did the same thing for the algorithm.
Now selecting the value of n clusters to be three.
And we are changing anything else.
So you see that we get an output from our model like this.
And let's give a scatter plot.
I don't think that will require,
but we get something similar to this,
whereby we have this as a centroid,
another centroid present here,
another centroid present here.
And once we have this, we can now see this part,
which is a new aspect that we haven't gone so far.
So now clustering evaluation, but using ground truth.
We are going to evaluate the cluster,
but we have some ground truth information
because we have this class information.
So from a skelearn import matrix is same.
And now we have these two things.
Levels two and the predicted them.
Levels two is Y.
Y is something that we have already selected.
I'm just for your reference, I'm just printing Y.
So this is Y.
Y is nothing but what we get from the class attribute
of the data set.
So this is what Y means.
So we are storing it in this label underscore true.
So this is the true label that we want to represent
from our model, that our model we want to predict.
And this is the predicted level.
So this is something that the model has predicted,
the values of C, right?
So this is for, of course, for K value of three,
as you can understand that we have did.
Now we want to run this RAND score.
Now what this RAND score is, again, let's see.
So RAND score, given the knowledge of the ground truth
class assignments to another clustering algorithms levels,
the RAND index is a function that measures the similarity
of the two assignments, ignoring the permutations, right?
You want the similarity to be higher, always.
So in this case, let's run this.
And we get a value of 0.9265, something like that, right?
These are very, very similar.
So these clusters are very quite similar.
So we can say that most of the classes,
or 92% of the classes that are present in the actual levels
are being represented by our model.
Even after doing this PCA, where we reduce the number
of features to three from, let's say, 10 features,
and then running the clustering algorithm,
we were able to achieve a 92% of accuracy
without having the labeled information.
So you can see the perfect leveling is scored as one.
Poorly agreeing levels, the score will be either negative
or close to zero.
So anything which is close to one is accepted.
There is something known as, okay,
so this is for adjusted RAND index.
So it is very, very similar to RAND index,
but it is normalized again.
So the thing that we'll observe from this RAND index,
we'll get the similar observation
from adjusted RAND index as well.
So it is 0.83489, right?
Now there is another, like, evaluation metric,
MI-based scores, known as the Mutual Information-based Score
and this is also something that we can use
the labeled information for the cluster.
So one can palmute zero and one in the predicted levels,
rename two to three and get the same score.
This basically takes into account
that the naming can be different
because we cannot name properly the perfect levels
in our dataset for the clustering algorithms.
So this is the important part.
So a perfect leveling is again scored as one
and this is not too far Mutual Info Score,
which is therefore harder to judge.
This means that we want this score to be
as close to one as possible.
So non-positive scores, again, I think, yeah.
So if there are non-positive scores, that are also bad, right?
So if there are negative scores,
anything close to zero is bad.
So to run this Mutual Information-based Score Scoring,
we just, again, give to these two levels
and the predicted levels
and we are just going to run this function.
So once you run this function,
you will see that we get a score of 0.8196.
And there is something known as this V-measure also
and this V-measure is again another metric
and all of this metric actually is doing the same thing,
but knowing this different metric is very, very important
because in some dataset, probably some metric
will not be helpful for you.
So 0.00 is bad and one is a perfect scoring.
So we'll see that there is a hyper-parameter here.
You see that there is a hyper-parameter beta, right?
So by default, it is zero
and you can change this hyper-parameter beta value.
So this beta hyper-parameter is actually used
to set that how much flexibility you want
in your prediction levels, basically prediction level
and the two level findings.
And it is by default set to one, right?
So it assumes that you want the exact matching
of the levels and the predicted values.
So more weight will be attributed to
homogeneity and greater value than one.
So let's try to see the homogeneity score,
the completeness score and the V-score.
And all of this takes the level two and the predictor level.
And we run this and we see that we get a different score
and we want this score to be closer to one.
Again, we have this flow-smallow score
and this score ranges from zero to one
and perfect leveling is scored as again one.
So for all these metrics, the perfect score is one
and bad score is zero.
Only the CELOT score, you get a negative score
from minus one to plus one.
And again, we just write this matrix
where we give this flow-smallow score
and we give these two levels and the predicted levels, right?
So this is the aspect of the entire
K-means clustering algorithm.
I think we have gone to an end for this K-means one,
but now we will start with the understanding
of hierarchical clustering algorithm using SQL on package.
Again, we are going to work with hierarchical algorithm
because of some of the important aspect that it provides.
So for K-means, you always need to have the value of K
beforehand you start any of the functionalities of the model.
But if you don't have the value of K,
you have to identify using some method
that we discussed like elbow method or some other method.
Or maybe some prior information if you have.
But for general thing, you can understand
the value of K identification is very, very difficult.
But here in hierarchical algorithm,
you don't need to identify the value of K,
at least not before the algorithm is ended.
So here in hierarchical algorithm,
you want to cluster the hierarchies.
Second thing is that you cannot use
this K-means clustering algorithm
where you have, for example, data that are very, very close together,
where they are merging, where they are overlapping.
But there is an aspect of hierarchical clustering
that you can use to actually cluster the overlapped clusters
because it is hierarchy based.
So it will capture the hierarchy of the overlap
and then it can distinguish between the objects
or the items that are present in that particular.
So the name of the algorithm is again
like hierarchical algorithm,
but with the detection of different clusters
that are present together.
So this is the general algorithm.
I think you have gone through the algorithm
in the theory class.
I'm not going through the algorithm,
but the algorithm suggests that you start from one end
of the clusters where you consider all the items
that are present to be in one cluster.
Then you break down one by one.
And then you reach up to point
where all the different points belongs to a different cluster
or belongs to a number of clusters that you have set.
Now let's continue.
So we want to visualize the data again.
It's similar.
So we get the scatter plot
of these three different clusters.
Let's see how we can use hierarchical algorithm now
to cluster these data points.
So for hierarchical clustering,
we'll select the hierarchical clusters
based on this hierarchy class.
And we are going to take the two objects,
the dendrogram and the linkage.
So in the theory class, you have already gone through this.
I'm not going to explain this much,
but most of the things remain same
as the chemist clustering algorithm.
And just for your clarification,
in the assignment for today's class,
we are going to only use the chemist clustering algorithm.
So if you are familiar
with the chemist clustering algorithm,
you can go ahead with the work of that.
And this is for your understanding only.
So we have not given any assignment
on this hierarchical clustering.
So this data is again the zip of this X and Y parameters.
And once we have this, we're going to create a linkage.
And we can create multiple type of linkages.
So let's create the linkage based on this.
So one linkage is considered to be Z1.
I can just zoom in a bit, Z1.
And the linkage where that forming using the data,
we have to pass the data
and the type of the linkage that we are forming.
So we're forming a single linkage.
And the metric of the distance
that we are going to use is Euclidean.
So we're keeping it fixed for all the other linkages also.
For Z2, we're using the complete linkage method.
And for Z3, we're using the average linkage method.
So this linkage, when we are assigning to different value,
and sorry, Z4 is there and Z5 is there,
where we are again using different linkage methods.
So one is word and the other is centroid linkage method.
So from Z1 to Z5, we have used the different linkages.
Now let's print for Z1, what will be the dendrogram, right?
So we are just, this is a very simple plot.
So we are going to plot this dendrogram Z1
and the plot will be a single, that I told you the single.
Let's just print this.
Okay, so dendrogram is not defined.
I think I have,
okay, I think I have missed that dendrogram part.
Let's consider.
I think it is present here.
Yeah, we have defined dendrogram, right?
Okay, okay, sorry, so I will just,
I will just put it here, okay?
So I'll just put it here.
Okay, so I will just put it here.
Yeah, so I think I have not initialized
the dendrogram that time.
So, okay, I can just play over this.
So once we have this dendrogram,
so we haven't initialized this linkages.
That's why we were getting the error.
So yeah, so we have this plot again.
We can just plot it and we can see
that the data set that we had is plotted here.
But here you see that we are starting
from all these clusters where we have, okay,
I'll just zoom out a bit if we can see it properly.
Yeah, so we end up with all these particular data points
that we have on different clusters.
And then we keep on adding up one by one together.
So for example, this 26 is a cluster
that is, okay, not 26.
Let's consider, let's say 23 and 25.
So these clusters are very, very similar.
So that's why they are in the same place.
And they become a single dendrogram, as you can see.
Then again, we are considering this to be,
this two to be in the same cluster,
this two to be in the same cluster.
So this is how a clustering is formed
for the hierarchical clustering.
And once we have this, you can see
it is very, very easy for us
because we are not providing the value of k
like in the k means.
And we can cut in any value of k.
So for example, we want the value of k to be two.
So two clusters I want.
So I can just cut it here.
I can just cut it here.
And I can have one cluster that is represented
by this orange and another cluster
that is represented by this green part.
If I, for example, want the value of k equals to three,
I can just fill out this orange part.
This left side of the green part,
basically I'm cutting it here.
So I'm getting this three part.
So this is one part.
This is another part.
And this is the third part, right?
So this is the three class.
And if we are going to increase the value of k,
so we can just chop off some of the lines here
and we can get the number of clusters.
So you can understand that we don't need
to provide the value of k.
It can work on overlapping clusters.
And the most important thing is that we can select
or prune any number of clusters once we are complete
the entire clustering algorithm is done.
So we can do this for all the other dendrograms we can see.
And you will get a little bit different clusters
for all the different types of dendrograms.
So now we are going to evaluate the cluster
without the ground truth.
It is the same thing that we did earlier.
But here you see that how we can get the different clusters
that we have, right?
So the different clusters we can get using the F cluster.
And we can give here the dendrogram basically
that we want to give.
So we are giving this Z4 as an input to the model.
We are giving the number of classes.
It should calculate basically the k value now
because we have to give the value of k here.
And the criteria is given as the maximum number
of clusters that can be formed.
And you can get the value of C here,
basically the clustered values.
So with this clustered values, we'll
see that we can use the exact same evaluation
matrix where we didn't have the ground truth,
like the Ciluity coefficient, dv index, h index, and all.
And we can use those to evaluate the algorithm.
So we just evaluate the algorithm here.
And let's see what is the score that we get
for a value of k equals to 3.
And we see that we get a value of 0.75,
which is a very good cluster as per the standard matrix
of Ciluity coefficient.
Similarly, we can get the ch index and the dv index.
So for the similar thing, you can go ahead
with the real-life data.
You can have multiple data points.
The code generally doesn't change much.
Only the concept of you will be required.
So I think we need to end this with the questions
that we want to answer.
I think we can start the question and think session.
Could you please explain why we are not getting the Ciluity
coefficient as 1 for this data?
Yes.
So as you can understand, we are getting an error value.
So let me just show you like this.
So what you are doing in the measurement
of this coefficient, Ciluity coefficient,
is that you are getting this centroid value.
And for, let's say, these are the clusters.
These are the clusters.
And there are other clusters, 0, 0, in some other parts.
And you are measuring the distance between this x point
and this 0 point, which gives us the error value.
So it gives us an value of error.
And we don't know exactly whether this particular thing
belongs to x class or not in reality,
because we don't have the labels of the data.
For that, we cannot get an 1 as an output
for the Ciluity coefficient.
I think this answers your question.
So this is an error value.
And you don't get an 1, even if the clusters are very, very
perfect.
How to decide which metric to be used.
Yeah, so for most of the aspects, the metrics that we use
are very, very similar.
So one aspect is that if you have a label data,
of course, if you are creating your own algorithm,
if you are working with an already existing algorithm
and you want to work with your own data, that has labels.
But you somehow want to use unsupervised methods,
you can use the clustering algorithm's evaluation
metrics, like the RAN index that we discussed,
where it actually uses the labels.
And if you don't have a label data,
of course, you end up with all these methods,
like Ciluity coefficient or H index or DB index,
that don't actually require any kind of labeled information.
So this is the one aspect of how you
to select the evaluation metrics.
The second thing is that all of these measures
are basically capturing the error in your model.
And they similarly work in different algorithms,
but they work in the same fashion.
And probably you will not end up using a single method,
but rather you will end up, for example, like we did here,
you will end up using three different metrics
to get a general idea like how better your model performs.
So I think this answers your question.
Is there any alternative to zip?
OK, so you know this zip function
that we have used in this particular hands-on
is used to actually just combine the two different labels
of the data, two different attributes, features of the data.
But in reality, we'll end up having different kinds of data.
We'll end up having data that are, for example,
spread out across different variations.
There could be some data that is in the form of dictionary.
So you have to translate it to the form
that we have discussed.
You may use zip or you may not use zip.
So that is not a handy thing, like you
have to use zip every time.
So you can use any of the alternatives.
But as you can ask me, your question
is specifically if we can use something alternative to zip.
So for that aspect or that part, we don't actually
have anything alternative to zip.
We don't require anything alternative to zip.
It's the most easiest thing you can do.
You can just take two lists and we can just zip them
to get the features.
So I think you don't require anything else at that moment.
But yes, without zip also, it is possible
because for different data, you'll
be working with different data sets.
So that there is the basic Python things,
I think that will be quite easy for you to understand later
on.
How can you determine the meaning or level
of each cluster in Kingston if you don't have prior knowledge
of the levels?
Yeah, so you know, like in clustering algorithms,
we will not end up having knowing the levels.
So which particular levels belongs to?
So one thing we already discussed that you have to know it.
You have to go through the data.
If possible, then you can judge that this could
be one of the levels, where basically natural language
takes levels.
And if you don't have any prior knowledge,
you usually don't end up having these levels.
And in real life, the problems that we
solve in computer science actually
don't require these natural language levels to be present.
Because we just want these data points
to be clustered into different sections
without requiring to know that which particular cluster is
meant for which particular thing.
So these levels, you have to know there are only two ways.
If you have prior knowledge, or if you
have good understanding of the data that you are looking for.
Other than that, it's not required most of the time
if you're using a clustering algorithm.
For PCA, how will we decide as how many features
should be removed without impacting our models?
Yes, so this we didn't discuss in our aspect of our hands-on.
So for that, we use different cross validation techniques.
And the cross validation techniques
actually takes care of the values
that you can provide to the PCA as the number of components.
So you can select, for example, number of components
to be ranging from 3 to 7.
And we can select the best value of this number of components
from this cross validation technique.
We haven't discussed, but probably in machine learning class
and all that will be discussed.
This PCA used on all features.
For example, if there are 10 features,
but two of them are useful, and I only
want to reduce dimension of the other eight.
So we can make sure to reduce the dimensions.
So this is a good question.
Basically, in our test case, we have used all the features.
And as you can understand, feature selection and feature
extraction is a very huge thing and a very important thing
at least aspect for the machine learning.
So in machine learning, selecting the best features
will give you a very good model.
So in our case, we have selected all the 10 features.
We haven't distinguished that this is a good feature
or this is not a good feature.
But yes, there are different ways
by which you can use some features, as we have discussed.
If you know prior that these features are important,
you can select those features.
So that becomes a part of the feature selection,
of you selecting the features.
And if you have some remaining features,
you can just use this PCA technique
to reduce the dimension of the other features.
But yeah, this is a very detailed explanation
is required for this.
But there are ways that you can use
to select the number of components also.
So it's done.
OK, thank you.